our next presenter is chitra ramalingam
who is lecturer in history of science
and medicine as well as history
professor ramalingam is a historian of
science and historian of photography her
research teaching and curatorial work
range broadly across topics in science
and visual and material culture with a
particular focus on the visual culture
of physics in the 19th and 20th
centuries on 19th century ways of seeing
especially optical illusions optical
toys and the pre-history of cinema
the early history of
photography
changing discourses about photography as
art or science and decolonial museum
practice
her first book to see a spark experiment
in visual experience in victorian
science uses the history of a single
scientific object the electric spark to
track how physicists manage their visual
experience in the laboratory
she has co-edited a volume of essays by
art historians and historians of science
on the photographic pioneer and
victorian gentleman of science william
henry fox talbot
titled william henry fox talbot beyond
photography and co-curated an exhibition
on talbot in 2010 at the wren library
the university of cambridge
she's curated exhibitions on early
photography on antiquarianism and
architectural photography and on social
portraiture in post-1945 british
photography
ongoing projects include a book project
on the laboratory as image archive in
the modern physical sciences a material
history of talbot's photographic
publication the pencil of nature in
collaboration with conservation
scientists at yale's institution for the
preservation of cultural heritage
fixing and fading
photographic histories an exhibition and
book on the science and aesthetics of
fading in 19th century and contemporary
photography and out of place a series of
experimental installations involving
re-situating objects from yale's natural
history collections about which we'll
hear more
welcome professor ramalingam
[Applause]
thank you
hi everybody
um hold on let me just get situated here
um
thank you so much to the organizers of
this event for giving us all the
opportunity to think broadly and
humanistically together across yale
collections and resources and i'm
especially glad to be following
ned cook um who's um
i've had some of the most kind of
humbling and and and um illuminating
experiences that i've had at yale have
been in in the teach-ins that he
described organizing earlier
um
so i want to talk to you
all today um about some work that
emerged out of my own interdisciplinary
practice as a curator and an academic
working between history of science
history of art and museum studies
a few years ago i started a project
which i called out of place which is a
kind of ongoing research engagement with
yale's varied collections
um and in this project i'm working with
a number of various wonderful
collaborators both on and off campus
to bring seemingly unconnected unrelated
objects from the
museums of science art and culture into
conversation with one another
and this project will result in a series
of online publications and displays over
the next two or three years
there's one planned for the yale
university art gallery
hopefully the peabody museum when they
reopen in 2024 and also at the tark
gallery in mumbai and hopefully other
venues as well
so today i want to explain to you all
the process and the practice behind the
first outcome of this project which i've
called a british mineralogy
in which i collaborated with an indian
artist based in delhi named garema gupta
this project explores the histories and
layer geographies and visual landscapes
of minerals at yale's peabody museum of
natural history
so in a natural history display like
this classic classic teaching display of
minerals that you can see on the left
from yale's peabody museum
natural objects like minerals from
across the globe are typically
identified with a specific locality of
origin so the one place which is known
to have occurred in nature
all other places through which that
object may have passed on route to the
museum on its passage through human
culture and history are not usually
relevant
in the collections of the yale center
for british art which you can see on the
right and where i worked as a
photography curator until a few months
ago
there are objects made in places around
the british isles but also all around
the world made by people of many
backgrounds become notionally british by
virtue of being there
geopolitical relations for certain
periods of time bound those people and
places to britain to its state its
fortunes and its aesthetic styles
sometimes creating rich hybrid styles
like the so-called company school of
indian painting masters such as sheikh
zayn aldine
natural history museums of course are
understood to tell us powerful stories
about nature
while we go to art museums to hear and
see powerful stories about culture and
identity
now this project arose from a number of
generative dissonances i guess i would
say
that i experienced during my four years
as a curator at the yale center for
british art
so on the one hand disciplinary
dissonance as a cultural historian of
science employed in an art museum
but then on a more personal level also
as a diasporic indian american at an
institution whose unstable vision of
british art depended so much on
exoticized images of people and places
of the global south
so as i kind of was conducting my work
there on the photography collection
which is not related to what i'm showing
you today
i kept thinking about what other
histories were entangled with the
history of british art within the walls
of that institution but were unable or
unavailable rather via the museum's fine
art collections
um its disciplinary methods and its
conventions of display
gradually i came to hone in on the
peabody's mineralogy collection and it
will become clear why i turned there in
a moment
i selected a group of 10 mineral
specimens in conversation with the
collection manager at peabody the
collection manager for minerals and
meteoritics
these 10 objects are it's actually
technically i think 13 objects but as
you can see some of them are grouped
by by mineral type
they were originally gathered from
locations in the british isles but also
in southern africa eastern australia sri
lanka and western india
they were collected at the peabody from
around the mid 19th century through the
early 21st centuries
each of them passing first through
british networks of power knowledge
value and exchange
at its height as you probably know at
the start of the 20th century the
british empire famously encompassed the
entire earth
not only with respect to territories
under direct colonial control but also
wider business and trade interests this
is a map of the british controlled
global telegraphy network around i think
1901 yeah
but british imperial ambitions did not
simply aim to cover the earth's surface
they also sought to reach deep below the
earth's surface
mining and engineering in britain and
its former empire are associated with
global histories of migration inequality
and exploitation
with the transformation of terrain and
with ecological disasters past present
and future
so these 10 um
objects which i called migrant minerals
they contained valuable materials from
the prosaic to the precious
graphite tin copper
diamond and more
and they were brought forth from the
earth
through the skilled labor of people
whose lives became entangled
um with them and with the technological
landscapes of extraction around them and
these are images of um the kimberley
mines in south africa one of the most
notorious diamond mines in the region
some of these images are from yale
collections like like this stereo pair
and the others are not
once unearthed
these objects embarked on voyages across
the globe participating in the global
flows of people and commodities that
underlay british power in a period of
high empire
and finally they were assimilated into a
natural history collection
where they shed some of these pasts in
order to become emblems of nature
apparently outside culture and outside
history they had become mineralogical
specimens
so in this project i was asking what
kind of mineralogy
might embrace and acknowledge these
stories of excavation translocation
transformation and arrival
rather than effacing them in the name of
nature
and i ended up calling this project a
british mineralogy and in this i was
inspired or
more precisely i was provoked
by the london artist and naturalist
james sowerby
in the early 19th century sowerby
published a multi-volume treatise which
he called british mineralogy so no
article just british mineralogy
this was the first major illustrated
mineralogical publication in europe
installed in um or issued in
installments between 1804 and 1817
sowerby's work was visually
groundbreaking with
hand-colored engravings based on
individual mineral specimens
there were two sets of books so first
the first volumes british mineralogy
um were followed a few years later by
their counterpart which was a large
single volume called exotic mineralogy
but sowerby regularly undermined his own
proposed distinction between the british
in this first set of volumes and the
exotic in the final set
in his text the words british english
native
foreign and exotic carried a lot of
weight and there were suggestive
slippages and ambiguities throughout
both the british and the exotic
mineralogy project for sour bee were
limited to reproducing specimens that
were held in london-based mineral
collections which themselves depended of
course upon networks of british
travelers to distant lands
and in his project um even a meteorite
so a piece of stone that was theorized
to have fallen from the heavens an
object that's literally from outer space
um was found to be british it was
included as part of british mineralogy
in the fifth volume sour be observed
what has been thought remarkable is that
this work on british mineralogy should
include so many subjects previously
considered as foreign
so i was looking through sowerby's
drawings and his text while i researched
these ten mineral specimens and i began
to wonder what it would look like to
propose a different kind of british
mineralogy
sowerby's work was an exercise in
drawing the boundaries of locale and
belonging and britishness
in a quite different way than either the
peabody museum or the yale center for
british art did or for that matter
quite different from how a present-day
uk immigration officer would draw those
boundaries
his drawings did not depict the
landscapes from which those specimens
were extracted or the people involved in
doing so although his text did
occasionally describe both the people or
the
landscapes and so it was at this point
that i realized that my project could
not simply be what it had been
originally conceived as which was it was
going to be an exhibition of minerals
accompanied by a text that was grounded
in my historical research into the
objects but the more time i spent with
sowerby the more urgently i felt that
this project required a visual practice
as a part of it a non-textual way of
restoring a multi-layered sense of place
and belonging to each object
and at this point in my research i had
begun to assemble a kind of visual
archive for each mineral as i researched
it so i was finding historical
photographs diagrams maps printed texts
and other documents
many of which were in yale collection
some of which were
things i had access digitally elsewhere
and all the historical images that i'm
showing you today are from this archive
that i assembled
and i felt like something needed to be
done with them as part of this project
something thoughtful that didn't just
reproduce the visual conventions of the
colonial gaze
and in any case i was sometimes
in this research coming across
disturbing and graphic imagery of abuse
and violence including
things that i found in yale collections
again images that i couldn't bring
myself to even save in my database let
alone contemplate publishing
and this was when i came across the work
of the indian artist and researcher
garema gupta based in delhi and i'm
showing you the work here by her that
caused me to reach out to her in the
first place
gutima's work is about the environmental
history of south and southeast asia
she makes drawings observational
drawings of natural objects rocks plants
animals and then she layers them with
drawings of archival materials that
she's found in her own research and she
does this in order to make sense of the
visual and ecological legacies of trade
and migration histories and european
colonial expansion in the region and so
in the work shown here she uses a leaf
of paper from the account books of an
oil palm plantation company in malaysia
as the basis for a drawing of two oil
palm flower heads male and female
and
she creates these layered installations
of drawings in light boxes
um and so you can kind of see the kind
of documentary layer and the
observational
drawing layer kind of merging together
in these light objects
and she does this in order to explore
visually a conflict over land use and
ecological change in the malaysian
archipelago
so i encountered this work by her and i
approached her about a year and a half
ago this was just before the pandemic
went global
and she and i began a conversation about
this project that eventually led to a
full collaboration between us
and so the 10 specimens um that you saw
earlier
eventually became over the course of
2020
10 drawings
and i'm just going to briefly scroll
through all 10 of them right now and
then i'll dive deeply into one of them
before i finish my talk
so i'm going to um
finish with the kind of the rest of my
talk will be telling you the story of
this object from the peabody museum here
one of the ten specimens that i honed in
on for this project and the first one
that i researched
now the only documentation in the
peabody archives for this beautiful
chunk of rock and crystal is the
handwritten label that you can see on it
and that's zoomed in on the right
so the label identifies this mineral as
apophyllite with still bite
and the other information on this label
helps us track the object's origins to a
place called poor got a treacherous pass
in the northern part of the western gods
the western ghats are a mountain range
that run up much of the western coast of
india
these basalt mountains were formed
through violent volcanic eruptions
around 66 million years ago
in the mid-19th century they presented a
natural barrier between the
british-controlled port city of bombay
and the rich resources of the indian
interior
so it was nearly impossible for any kind
of wheeled vehicle to traverse these
mountains and so if the british wanted
indian commodities like silk opium
cotton spices
if they wanted these things to flow
efficiently overseas for trade they
needed a rail line to cut across the
mountains
and so in 1856 the british established
the great india peninsula railway
company and they set out to make it
happen
laying these new rail lines was the
largest and most labor-intensive civil
engineering project of the british
government in india
and it coincided with violent rebellions
that saw the british almost lose control
of northern india in 1857.
the project was carried out over seven
years um 1856 to 1863 and this places it
right around the same time as the
construction of the suez canal
the poor got works actually employed
more workers than the suez project and
ultimately it killed many more people
building this rail line was dangerous
work in precipitous terrain
there were severe extremes of weather in
the mountains and poor sanitation in the
worker camps
ultimately over the seven years of this
project around 25 000 workers died most
of them from cholera which swept every
year through the workers camps
but vast numbers of laborers around 42
000 people a year at the height of this
project migrated seasonally across an
extensive part of western and southern
india to work on the new railway line
they were mostly landless peasants and
tribal people who had been relegated to
the margins of indian society both men
and women
british railway overseers recruited and
organized workers ethnographically
identifying specific caste communities
with specific labor requirements and so
this railway works was also part of a
process that transformed
fluid regional community identities into
hardened stereotypes locked into a
hierarchy of skills and status and a
yearly cycle of migration and contract
work
so these railway works
set a lot of things in motion across the
mountains then
capital commodities and people
and then on a smaller scale they also
sent minerals in motion as well
because blasting tunnels through the
mountains
um in this place exposed dazzling caves
um lined with crystals up to six feet
wide
even today these caves are the world's
most they produce the most spectacular
examples in the world of apophyllite
this kind of crystal that only forms in
this kind of volcanic rock
some of the indian earth workers who
were involved in the railway project
took large crystals from these caves
which the caves became known as the
jewel tunnels
and they embedded them into the mud
walls of their huts in the workers camps
as decoration and as trophy
the chief railway engineer who was an
englishman named james barkley had the
largest specimens saved to distribute to
natural history museums
some of them stayed within india but
most were sent to britain
there they enabled british scientists
and geologists to develop theories for
how crystals like these form following
volcanic disturbances
and one of these samples ended up in the
hands of geologist neville story
masculine who was the keeper of minerals
at the british museum in london his name
is actually on the handwritten label
there you can't really see it but it
says donor ns masculine
he eventually gifted it to yale where it
now resides
so this crystal specimen traveled from
deep inside a mountain in western india
to the british museum in london and then
finally on to new haven
and it did so on a journey shaped by
indian histories of labor migration and
transportation which transformed an
entire landscape and shored up british
imperial control over the indian
subcontinent
so this was the story that i had begun
to delineate for myself around this
object the first one that i researched
as part of this project and i'd
assembled this visual archive that i
mentioned before of photographs and maps
and engravings
and charts
just as the pandemic upended our plans
for garimagarhgupta the artist
the original plan was for her to come to
new haven work closely with me observe
the objects and make art as a result but
amid lockdowns and travel restrictions
we reconceived the project as a remote
engagement between us
mediated by high-resolution digital
photography cloud databases google
documents and zoom
for garma whose work typically involves
extensive fieldwork and travel across
asia
observing and drawing this specimen of
apophyllite in raw involved a real
remaking of her practice she felt her
way into each specimen by zooming deep
into the digital images that the peabody
museum provided
finding in each one a kind of micro
landscape of its own
and when her drawing was complete the
the main observational drawing of the
specimen
she then considered its relation to the
real former landscape from which the
specimen had been excavated and to the
charts and maps and diagrams that i'd
provided for her and which we talked
about in extensive conversations
um and you know she experimented with
placing the drawings against retraced
maps of the borgot railway cuttings
and so ultimately here is the final work
that she created the the whole work is
on the left and then i've kind of zoomed
in on the specimen on the right
and it's displayed on a light box like i
was explaining earlier so that the kind
of like multiple layers of the image and
therefore the layers of history in this
object could emerge
and so for each of the objects we had a
kind of back and forth like this um and
our my text that i wrote for each one
and the illustrations that garuma
produced were to have developed
collaboratively through that process
and together my words and her
illustrations engage in a kind of
exploratory practice of place making
bringing into view the transformation of
the physical landscape from which the
mineral has come the political and
social landscape through which it has
traveled and the surface of the object
as a landscape of its own
this just another example a close-up of
her drawing of the kimberley mine
diamonds
the coming into being of a natural
history specimen is a transformative
journey in which it sheds a richer sense
of place and its movement through
culture
and through this collaboration we have
tried to help these objects carry their
journeys into the present rather than
leaving them behind
thank you
[Applause]
can you talk a little bit more about um
other
are there other projects like this that
you sort of come across
that you like to take on or other ways
in which you'd like to see this work at
hall i mean it's very exciting that the
exhibitions will actually
come online
yeah
do you mean other projects here at yale
as part of this or do you mean yeah
yeah
yeah yeah absolutely
yeah yeah definitely um so i had um
while i was at this yale center for
british art i had the opportunity to
work with a graduate research assistant
on this project kind of investigating
objects and trying to find i had already
kind of conceived the mineralogy project
on my own and i wanted um
the kind of next stage to emerge more
collaboratively with other partners at
yale
um
the the student that i worked with menon
go day um
we eventually came up with an idea
together that was fully kind of
co-conceived such that
we're now kind of
co-co-curators fully equal collaborators
on the next stage of this um which we're
calling well it's a provisional title
right now but we're calling it the
octants journey and so we've now we've
honed in on an 18th century navigational
instrument that's in the peabody's
scientific instruments collection
um this is an object that's used to
establish latitude at sea
um and we are working
as part of an exhibition on scientific
instruments it's going to happen at the
art gallery the yale university art
gallery in a couple of years um we're
going to be doing a kind of intervention
into that exhibition where this where
this navigational instrument basically
travels around the exhibition
encountering objects in it and narrating
its own history um in a printed booklet
and on social media and we're what we're
doing is we're playfully adapting an
18th century literary genre called the
it narrative where
objects that are kind of circulating
around the world um are imbued with
narrative power and tell their own
stories um and so we're kind of we're
imagining the octent this this
navigational instrument as a um as a
kind of stand-in for the museum visitor
so we're dramatizing the process by
which meaning is made in a museum
through these encounters between the
octane and these objects and the idea is
that as it explores objects at the
gallery it is
questioning its own role as a kind of
navigational instrument from this period
of imperial expansion thinking about its
own role in astronomical expeditions
um
genocide and enslavement
kind of
extractive colonialism
and yeah just trying to kind of
understand its own implication in those
histories
so that's a kind of you know it's a very
different sort of a project than this
but like this the idea is to kind of
bring objects that don't seem to have
anything to do with each other
um and use them to really question the
categories that have separated them in
museums you know because the yale
museums
do a lot of collaborative work together
but still fundamentally they have these
different kind of conventions of display
and ways of giving meaning to objects
that
illuminate them deeply but also hide
certain aspects of them and i think one
of the great possibilities of
interdisciplinary humanistic work at a
university like yale that's had a couple
of years of collecting history is that
they're it's not just that the
collections are rich and deep as
resources for our own work but they are
an invitation
to um kind of turn the lens on the
institution themselves and ask really
important questions about well why is
this object here why has it been
identified as this kind of object rather
than another kind of object and what
other sorts of histories might it tell
yeah i mean that's that's the hope
that's the hope right is to um kind of
by collaborating with the different
museums start to
inspire
changes and kind of experiments and how
they do things
i think i mean maybe another way of
describing what i'm after in this
project is that um
i think many now i'm not talking about
yale i'm talking about um kind of
european and american museums more
broadly um
the place where this kind of kind of
creative
and playful and kind of unexpected work
happens is through artist interventions
right like people invite the artist to
come in engage with the collection and
then either make work or select work in
a way that
kind of cuts across
the categories that have structured that
collection and i really believe in that
work and i find it really powerful but
my worry about it is that it segregates
that kind of critical work and says that
this is the work of the artist the
institution kind of follows its own
um
kind of dynamic that is that's not a
part of that and so you end up
displaying these kinds of interventions
rather than incorporating them into the
practice of the museum
um i don't
so i'm i'm really interested in finding
way you know as a curator i was trying
to do that from within i'm now
working from without again but also very
much with museums and so i
my hope is that we start to really
yeah change change the way these objects
meaning is displayed in all these
different spaces
thanks
[Music]
you